françois philippe champagne bonjour
merci d'être avec nous merci de m'avoir
invité
je chante en commençant par la gestion
du coroner virus on a reproché à votre
gouvernement la lenteur de
l'intervention en chine pour évacuer les
canadiens si vous aviez le refaire
qu'est ce que vous feriez différents
dans des circonstances comme ça la
première étape c'est d'abord évaluer les
besoins
ensuite deux seuils finaliser les
viandes s'occuper en soin de soi des
permis de logistique
quand je regarde l'arc du temps je me
dis au début quand ça commence c'était
au tour du 27 janvier
on avait deux canadiens canadiennes qui
nous demandait d'être rapatriés dans la
même journée
ce chiffre est passé de 2 environ 150
parce que vous savez la façon pour nous
de sarov dit l'oim ça va vite puis la
façon pour nous de savoir combien de
gens c'est qu'on a un site web où les
canadiens et canadiennes à l'étranger
peuvent s'enregistrer volontairement
plus on en a parlé plus de gens se sont
enregistrées donc je vous dirais que
quand je regarde langue du temps notre
réponse à était proportionnée elle était
évidemment aussi en ligne avec les
besoins qui est exprimé par les familles
que vous avez vu que ce nom blow fluctué
au cours de la semaine parce que des
gens finalement qui le garde qui décide
de venir il y en a qui décide de rester
alors on est là on va continuer d'être
là n'ont à peu près de deux tiers des
canadiens canadiennes qui ont rapatrié
chez nous on va avoir un deuxième avion
canadien pour s'assurer de ramener tout
le monde cet avion la partie rurale 10 à
partir de one sera chez nous le 11
février
donc vous êtes vous vous êtes satisfait
de la façon dont ça s'est déroulé je
regarde l'heure du temps je regarde les
besoins qui avait exprimé je regarde la
volonté des familles qui veulent être
rapatriés
je vous dirai dans les circonstances des
autorisations de la logistique qu'on
doit faire parce que amener un avion
once d'une chose monsieur thibault les
organiser la logistique faut que les
gens comprennent la ville de roanne cis
est plus grand que new york où l'on dort
donc avec 11 millions de population il
faut ce sur une fois qu'on donne le
manifeste aux autorités chinoises que se
manifeste la donne les autorisations aux
policiers plus ou moins devant chaque
résidence en écouter cet individu là
avec ce véhicule avec ce numéro de
plaque les audois de circuler pour ça en
a l'air ou pas c'était surtout ça puis
vous avez vu qu'une journée on a voulu
décoller on avait des vents trop forts
écoutez quand on ment quand on monte des
opérations complexes comme celle là il
faut s'ajuster
le vietnam a fermé son espace aérien on
m'a appelé durant la nuit pour me
demander d'intervenir avec la présidence
vietnamienne ce qu'on a fait c'est ça
des opérations complexes il faut
s'ajuster en fonction des blues dont
vous êtes satisfait qu'est ce qui reste
à faire maintenant
d'abord continuer d'offrir des services
consulaires vous savez on a deux équipes
d'urgence à one parce qu'il ya bon
nombre de canadiens qui ont décidé de
rester sur place
on a aussi un deuxième avion qui est un
qui va être en route dans le fond c'est
le premier avion qu'on avait quand qu'on
va renvoyer en chine pour ramener les
derniers à citoyens canadiens
canadiennes qui veulent revenir alors
c'est bon qu'il ya un petit peu de temps
tu les deux cas ça nous permet vraiment
de contact et tout le monde peut dire
voulez vous revenir s'ils voulaient
revenir ça c'est le deuxième avion qui
se passe pour vous ramener chez nous au
canada
votre homologue chinois vous a répondu
rapidement je pense qu'on a dit une
douzaine d'heures entre le moment où
vous l'avez vous l'avais contacté celui
vous rappeler ça vous amuse la surprise
cette répond valls était un signe
positif parce que vous savez en matière
de relations internationales
quand on demande des appels comme centre
et à ça peut prendre beaucoup plus que
12 heures le fait que à 12 heures le
ministre des affaires étrangères chinois
a accepté qu'on se parle et conduit un
appel d'environ 40 minutes je vous
dirais que ça démontre un peu d'abord
l'importance qu'on avait nous indiquer
de rapatrier ces canadiens loge chez
nous et oui je peux dire que la chine à
coopérer avec le canada quand je regarde
parce que vous savez monsieur thibault
là dedans
nous on est en contact avec tous les
alliés donc on sait exactement combien
de temps ça prend pour un combien de
temps ça prend pour l'eau et je peux
vous dire que si je regarde les
autorisations qu'on a demandé les visas
qu'on a demandé le temps que ça a pris
c'est vraiment en ligne avec tous les
autres alliés donc on est les autorités
chinoises ont coopéré avec le canada
pour rapatrier les gens les relations
entre le canada et la chine sont pas
particulièrement bonnes depuis
depuis un petit peu plus d'un an
maintenant avez vous l'impression qu'il
ya un certain rapprochement à cause de
l'urgence qu'on est en train de vivre
ses soeurs tech en pour moi chaque fois
qu'on a l'occasion de se parler c'est un
pas de plus il ya un peu une diplomatie
sanitaire quand on est en train de voir
ce qu'on peut faire ensemble et à chaque
fois que j'ai l'occasion de parler à mon
homologue chinois va évidemment je parle
du code des deux michael ce qu'on a
appelé ma cause par leur mac os covering
il ya aussi le cas de monsieur
challenger pour lequel vous êtes donc
parler de cas de virus a fini par être
abordées notamment soulève le soulève
systématiquement chaque occasion parce
que je rappelle que oui on a une crise
ou une urgence sanitaire auquel on doit
travailler ensemble mais je rappelle
toujours à mes homologues chinois que la
priorité absolue du canada c'est de
rapatrier évidemment les deux mac os
chez nous et vous l'impression que cette
crise là ça fait bouger les choses où ça
ça change la donne du côté chinois leur
perception par rapport à l'urgence
d'agir dans le cadet de michael madsen
bas je voudrais chaque opportunité et je
on s'est dit qu'on allait peut-être se
voir même à la conférence sur la
sécurité à munich donc à chaque fois
qu'on a la chance de se parler
ça nous amène plus proche d'une solution
évidemment pour cela dès demain vous
allez rencontrer vous souhaitez
rencontrer votre blog vous allez
rencontrer votre homologue chinois
munich on s'est dit au téléphone qu'on
allait essayer de se rencontrer parce
qu'évidemment de part et d'autre
beaucoup de choses qui se passent en
même temps donc si les horaires peuvent
se coordonner on s'est dit qu'on se
verrait à la conférence de munich la
semaine prochaine auront des deux magots
vous l'avez abordé est ce que les choses
ont changé ce que les choses se sont
améliorées dans ce dossier écoutez
la seule amélioration que moi je
considèrerai sait si les conditions de
détention des deux écoles s'améliorer
pour l'instant la réponse est non
évidemment ce que nous on veut obtenir
c'est la libération
évidemment de ces gens là qui reviennent
chez nous moi je continue de le dire
la détention arbitraire ça va à
l'encontre de toutes les rêves on est en
vain
moi je pense qu'entre et on est capables
de se parler et on est capable de faire
avancer les choses et c'est toujours ça
que je rappelle à nos homologues chinois
lors de nos discussions possibles vous
pour les ramener ici c'est que c'est
quoi vous et dès hier
évidemment parce que vous comprendrez
que chaque jour en détention c'est un
jour de trop mais évidemment on est
toujours à m
cette déduction la de l'avant à chaque
fois qu'on a l'opportunité avec les
autorités chinoises
changeons pays on parle de l'iran ou
est-ce que vous en êtes avec vos nevo
négociations et terrain-là actuelle dans
dossier de l'écrasement d'avion de alors
il reste trois choses il reste
évidemment les boîtes mois voilà alors
le mieux garni et moi on est allé
rencontrer le président la directrice
générale de l'organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale qui est basé à
montréal qui est une organisation de
l'onu pour leur demander d'intervenir
parce que l' annexe 13 la fameuse annexe
13 sur la convention de l'aviation
civile prévoit qu'en cas de désastre
aérien les boîtes noires doivent être
lues sans délai alors force est de
constater qu'après un mois on a un
problème
moi j'ai soulevé cet enjeu là avec mon
homologue iranien plus tôt la semaine
dernière qui dit qu'est ce qu'ils disent
ben au départ l'iran voulait acquérir
les compétences et les équipements
nécessaires pour faire ce travail là en
iran moi ce que je dis de façon très
claire c'est que force est de constater
qu'après un mois
or l'iran n'y est pas arrivé alors la
meilleure solution maintenant c'est à
dire ces boîtes noires lors maintenant
doivent aller à paris c'est clair que
tout le monde reconnaît que ceux qui ont
l'expertisé pour faire ce travail là ce
serait les autorités françaises tant au
niveau de l'équipement que l' expertise
et le canada pourrait participé comme
observateur tout comme évidemment des
ukrainiens évidemment les iraniens
ensuite de seuil à la compensation
statutaire que la compagnie aérienne
doit aux familles j'ai parlé au
président
la compagnie henan airlines pour lui
demander d'accélérer ce processus là et
en plus de ça évidemment c'est ce qu'on
appelle la compensation d'état c'est à
dire que quand l'état iranien reconnaît
la responsabilité la pleine
responsabilité pour cette tragédie là
évidemment sa vie avec des conséquences
est une des conséquences c'est
évidemment de compenser financièrement
les familles et en plus tu sois bien
évidemment il ya toutes les enquêtes
criminelles pour lequel on a intérêt
parce que nous on ce qu'on a dit avec le
premier depuis le départ on veut qu'ils
aient transparence on veut que les gens
qui soient responsables soient jugés on
veut que ça soit fait rapidement et
selon des standards internationaux qui
s'est passé dans ce dossier là parce
qu'au début on avait l'impression les
inspecteurs canadiennes sont rendus sur
nos terres ils ont vu les débris de
l'appareil
tout portait à croire que les
enregistreurs de vol ils allaient être
envoyés à paris ou à tout le moins un
endroit où on pourrait les analyses et
tout d'un coup ça a bloqué ou est-ce que
sable mais moi je juge les rendent non
pas par leur paroles mais par leur
action les jeunes jour par jour et
baylet des actions ils sont toujours à
téhéran les jeux c'est pour ça qu'on est
levée le temps est ce pour ça que le
canada a levé le ton a dit les familles
ont des ondes et demande le canada dès
demain la communauté internationale
s'interroge et j'ai toujours dit le
meilleur antidote à toutes sortes
d'histoires qui pourrait y avoir c'est
la transparence
alors moi ce que j'ai dit au ministre
iranien jeudi il faut qu'une décision
finale soit pris par le président
iranien pour dire maintenant force est
de constater qu'on n'a pas la capacité
technique on n'a pas l'expertisé pour le
faire et dans l'intérêt de la
transparence dans l'intérêt d'en arriver
à permettre à la communauté
internationale d'avoir les réponses
il faut que ça soit fait vous serez
cette fin de semaine en afrique
pour participer au sommet là bas des
pays d afrique n mais aussi pour parler
d'un siège canadien au conseil de
sécurité où est-ce qu'on en est rendu là
dedans mais on continue de faire valoir
que le canada au sein d'un conseil de
sécurité c'est une voie positive c'est
une voie moderne c'est une voix qui
rassemble moi je peux vous dire j'étais
au mali récemment je suis allé au maroc
je vois la communauté internationale
dire on a besoin de cette voie là
transatlantique le canada c'est le g7 et
g20
c'est la francophonie c'est comme un
waldsee l'otan c'est ce pays-là qui
inspire par ses valeurs par ce principe
un pays moderne qui met devant une
politique étrangère féministes qui met
de l'avant une politique sur les
changements climatiques
c'est cette voix l'homme moderne moi je
pourrais vous dire monsieur thibault je
l'entends les gens disent un canada ça
fait une différence autour d'une tasse
et plus et on veut l'entendre c'est plus
dur que ce que vous aviez imaginé comme
suit redoute elle est à new york pour
dire on va la voir le siège au conseil
bah c'est certain que dans une course
comme celle là il ya toujours de la
compétition mais ce que je constate de
plus en plus c'est que les gens disent
et j'étais par exemple avec la
francophonie imaginer la francophonie me
dit si on est un pays francophone
c'est clair qu'on doit aller avec le
canada donc cette francophonie là qu'il
va avoir une voix forte
on parle de sécurité économique là bas
on parle de développement on parle dead
c'est un peu ce discours là que
j'entends un peu partout donc vous vous
êtes optimiste
vous allez l'avoir le siège bah écoutez
je suis toujours prudent parce que dans
une course comme celle là mais c'est
certain qu'on va mettre tous les efforts
avec le premier ministre avec
l'ambassadeur blanchard pourquoi parce
que je pense que le canada fait une
différence dans le monde
quand le canada s'impliquent quand le
canada a maintenu sa voix le canada fait
une différence
et moi je dirais souvent c'est pas les
chiffres qui parlent mais c'est l'impact
du canada dernières données éléments on
a parlé de chine on a parlé de l'iran
votre priorité quelles sont elles s qui
en a des dossiers dont on parle pas
quand vous êtes arrivé dans un james et
deux trucs là outre les deux maiko
s'était pas sur l'écran radar sur quoi
vous auriez voulu passer du temps sur
quoi devriez vous passez du temps à
écouter la barre si j'écris un livre un
jour ça va s'appeler neuf jours en
janvier parce que effectivement qui
aurait pu dire que tout ça est vrai en
si peu
dans le début de l'année 20 20 c'est
certain qu'il faut s'occuper de cessange
l'autre résurgent court terme mais faut
garder une pensée stratégique le siège
au sein du conseil de sécurité ça fait
partie de la pensée stratégique le fait
par exemple de continuer de développer
des accords commerciaux bosse toujours
le canada c'est le seul pays du g7 avec
un accord de libre échange avec tous les
autres pays du g7
il ya évidemment de défendre l'esprit
des démocraties libérales qui est de
plus en plus je le dire sous pression à
travers le monde le multilatéralisme
comment on peut réformer ces grandes
questions là autant que ce soit
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
autant d'autres induction qui ont besoin
d'être modernisée pour faire face aux
enjeux du 21e siècle
je voudrais qu'on a pas mal de pain sur
la planche françois philippe chopin
merci beaucoup merci de m'avoir invité